nobody can call you a gang member or an
even remotely violent person after they
see your attempt at assaulting fred
durst
how do you know how you kind of drop
kicks look man
i don't know i don't even know how to
fight like a professional wrestler
exactly everything is the work
exactly i mean dude like
just a little while ago sitting right
here i thought of that i remember like
oh my god the [ __ ] of the the fred durst
attack
you know because i know he probably will
see this on this format and i would like
to say not just the fred durst but
everybody else on that stage including
uh uh uh was it dj lethal is this dj i
don't know all right
no it's not mugs is this dj i don't know
when was that uh i don't know [ __ ]
some years ago okay
but but uh but yeah i want to apologize
to everybody that was on that stage
because that was some whole [ __ ] man it
really was i wasn't up there to harm
nobody i really wasn't trying to drop
kick him because come man well you
clearly weren't trying too hard well
yeah it was like wrestling style but i
wanna play wrestling
somebody runs up on your stage when
you're up there that's right that's some
whole [ __ ] you know that's yours
that's your personal area for that hour
however long you're up there right and
coming inside of that is whole [ __ ] and
i violated that one
and i would like to personally apologize
to every man not just on that stage but
that was involved with that show and
that festival yeah
what surprised me about that was that
you weren't wearing your makeup thinking
oh it was like that was after we had
performed earlier you know what i'm
saying i think you would think i was in
flip-flops and basketball shorts and a
white theater
right it's like straight up like it was
came out of a [ __ ] meth house or
something the idea that you would step
on stage without your makeup was more
surprising to me than than how badly you
performed
i'm sure nobody has any hard feelings
about that feeling oh really yeah yeah
at first like from
first but rightfully so you know what
i'm saying but right time heals and if
there is any saltiness i apologize we
see that i'm sure when you see me you
can you can [ __ ] give me a [ __ ]
[ __ ] wrist burn there you go maybe
make it all good i mean dude i think
it's i think it's classic yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]